uh to continue we've seen him sacrifice
things we've seen him start pushing
pawns forward playing all these
surprising moves but still the world
champion he's such a good defender it's
going to be difficult to break through
his
final defenses
and uh i like this move from magnus you
know he puts his king on a light square
good technique yup and now aroni's given
another check so actually this is asking
magnus the question do you want a draw
are you going to repeat the position and
magnus says yes please
magnus is hoping for the draw right now
if aronia brings his rook back and gives
check then we're headed towards a
potential repetition of the position
so ironian is he going to find anything
better okay he gives a check
and i'm expecting to see magnus okay the
same way with king okay let's go to the
players because the game is about to end
it is a three-fold repetition who looks
happier neither looks that happy
it's just been such an entertaining game
such amazing high-level chess from both
sides no big blunders but some really
creative blows all right well magnussee
did seem to enjoy this game